just first of all would like to run
through some of the domestic
arrangements please can you please
ensure that your microphones are muted
when you're not speaking and if you fail
to do that you'll find that I'll
probably or someone may mute you please
don't take offense it's just to prevent
any background noise that may come
through it's obviously important we
don't interrupt each other if we use the
text box if you wish to speak and and
just put your say you would like to
speaker then I'll bring you in at the
relevant time please members are also
reminded not to use messaging chat
functions during the meeting unless it
is to record a report a pecuniary
non-pecuniary interest and if you wish
to make a proposal regarding the
applications before us if you notify me
that that's what you wish to do members
also reminded they should not have other
lines of communication open i Skype
chats and if you're contacted by a
third-party application or a third party
during an application can you please let
us know because no one should have the
ability to contact you during this
meeting if you're attending the meeting
to speak and you're interrupting the
meeting you will be asked to leave the
meeting additionally you'll be vice to
speak when it is your turn
we keep to the same rules as before
three minutes for anyone wishing to
speak and it will become clear that
there is in front of us on the screen
there will be a timer so that you'll be
able to see how much time has gone and
how much time is remaining I'd like to
remind everyone present this meeting
will be broadcast live and is being
broadcast live on the internet and will
be capable of repeated viewings the
whole of the meeting will also be
recorded except where they're
confidential exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting you'll be
deemed by the council to have consented
to being recorded by entering this
meeting as a speaker you're also
consenting to being recorded by the
council and to the possible use of those
sound recordings for webcasting and/or
training purposes the council members of
the public and press may record
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded I just like to run
through the people that are present on
the call with us today here we can call
on at any time to assist we have in
Dupre's who's our legal adviser welcome
in and we have Claire Philpott our
governance officer welcome Claire John
Pitman ji is in the call he's our area
planning manager welcome John and Jack
Wilkinson as the case officer we'll be
presenting today now we have the
applicant we have maybe with the members
of the public present on my list we have
the parish Clark
we have Caroline Walton and Chris Smith
who there's times we'll have the
opportunity to speak during the
application before us okay so and James
Caston is with us he's the ward member
who has the opportunity to speak on the
application but not to date so I'm going
to move us on to the agenda and the
first item on the agenda is apologies
for absence and substitutions can I ask
the governance officer to just roll call
the members present please Thank You
chair members when I call your name if
you could just indicate your presence
for me please
councillor Rachel eben present counselor
John field councillor
Lavinia adding him presents councillor
Matthew Hicks present
councillor Sarah Mansell present counsel
John Matheson councillor Richard mayor
present councillor Dave Miller present
and councillor James Kirsten
sorry present hit the wrong button sorry
thank you very much okay so we now move
to agenda item number two two
any declarations of pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest by members
members do you have any decorations to
declare John we can't hear you at all
can you try one more time no there is a
problem with your line John and what I
think you'll need to do is log out and
log in again you're coming here over
with a very high-pitched voice and it's
there's something wrong on the line
sorry John we can't hear any of that or
if you want to type anything but I think
if you log out and Ron has left good
we'll just give him one minute just to
log on again mr. chairman if I might
just say that um this exact same thing
happened in am seminar I'm just the
other day and it was because the member
was using a headset and as soon as he
unplugged their headset he was back to
normal again
okay I'm using a headset I thought I
only ever used a headset so okay we'll
try that let's see what's on it could be
that is all I'm saying
yeah am i back on your back and we can
hear you loud and clear so that's good
John the sixth time to log on I just
needed to declare two issues I neither
which are procuring
really the first issue is that on county
councillor for this area which I feel we
should know that's the Brantford
application the second thing I have an
involvement as a trustee with an
application which is mentioned a few
occasions at the Brantford end of Sprott
and the one that's mentioned adjacent to
the Worstell Road yes you do Thank You
Gavin cash the field yes I heard all
that and I'm happy to advice
the field has properly declared those
matters and well the first one is of not
usually is usually declared for the sake
of the performance but yeah they're both
as far as I'm concerned he doesn't know
nothing peculiar there thanks very much
okay and any other members have anything
to declare
nope okay to move on agenda item number
three decorations of lobbying now I
suspect all members have received an
email from the applicant any other
lobbying on that I think any anyone else
wish to register any further lobbying on
this application John field again just
that I have been lobbied over some
months you must remember at one time I
was board member for this area yeah
thank you
anyone else yeah Rick Meyer received an
email from Caroline Walton yeah I think
we all have received that email so I
think for the record we've all received
lobbying on on the applications before
us okay thank you very much members
agenda item number 4 is declarations of
personal site visits does anyone have a
personal site visit to declare no okay
thank you very much
agenda item number five is confirmation
the minutes of the meeting held on the
13th of May 2020 this is the leaders on
our papers on page 7 to 10 and if I just
run through each page if you have
anything that please just do feel free
to come in page 7 page 8 and page 9 is
everyone happy that I signed those is a
true record of the meeting if you're not
happy please speak otherwise I'll take
that as given thank you I'll sign those
afterwards okay agenda item number 6 to
receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the counselors petition
scheme could I ask please the
government's office to report on this do
we have in it
there's none received yeah thank you
very much okay agenda and I will now ask
the area planning manager to report on
the applications that were to be heard
by the committee but have subsequently
been withdrawn
are there any John
John paid Minji sorry counselor that
something went wrong here could you just
repeat the question for me under the
order of business it says that I will
now ask the area planning manager report
on any applications to be heard by the
committee but have been subsequently
withdrawn now that may be I know that
happened in the last meeting but is
there anything to this meeting then is
Dave unloaded
I'm not aware of anything chairman Thor
reporting at this time okay thank you
very much okay so we'll now go straight
to agenda item 7 schedule of planning
applications I'll now ask the case
officer dr wilkinson to introduce the
application to committee over to you
Thank You chair I'm just going to bring
up the PowerPoint which hoping you'll be
able to see
just why that's happening just to be
clear this is DC 1901 401 and DC 1901
six four nine land to the south of
Fitzgerald Road in Brantford
I think we've just lost Jack Oh together
so I'm sure he's got you back on here
again sorry cherry what happened there
that fixed so if everyone goes to the
widescreen you have a bigger picture in
front of you
Thank You chair good morning members
members of the public
I'm Jack wilkinson I'm a principal
planner in the DM service for Vibram at
Suffolk the first only item for today is
lying to the south or Fitzgerald Road in
Brantford you will know the two
application references as a twin track
application so in terms of what we're
here to determine today the planning
application is an outline application ie
the principle of development and access
this is summarized in the proposal as
outline time application with some
mutters reserved for a residential
development of up to 115 dwellings and
access including open space and
landscaping just to give you an idea of
where we are as depicted by the red
marker where amongst the Ipswich fringe
towards the southern extent of Brantford
a 14 to the east brought into the South
Claydon
and little Blake onto the north
as mentioned we are situated towards the
south of Brantford I will zoom in on
better quality image in a minute
the site is outline outlined as hatched
I think what is also worth mention is
the district boundary as depicted by the
black line which hopefully you can see
with my cursor so we have parish of
Brantford here and neighboring Broughton
in the district of Baber
towards the south as existing local plan
Brantford is defined as a key service
center and the extent of the blue line
shows the settlement boundary and the
application site is outlined in red just
to give you that distinction in terms of
the emerging joint local plan and that
reminds of limited weight but it is
worth mentioning with regards to
emerging policy LA 0:06
which does identify the site for
residential housing this is outlined on
page 26 of your papers you can see that
the red line outline is largely covered
within the cellar
in terms of the defined sight outline I
what we would rely upon in terms of the
plan and an accurate extent with detail
it is as shown you can also have ins the
defined blue line area the land is
divided by grade two and grades three
agricultural land much of the district
is set in this form and that's
worthwhile mentioning in terms of the
landscape quality in terms of how the
site looks from the air and indeed from
the ground which I'll take you onto in a
moment with some site photos the built
form as you can see is predominately to
the north I went to the backdrop of the
village which is where this site is
located towards the west we have to be
11 1 3 it's an arterial road the links
brantford to Broughton and it's which
edge along with a link north towards do
14 it's an arterial route the Fitzgerald
Road along the north as well with bus
stops leading into the centre of your
key service center of Brantford
just to remind members this is an
indicative master plan we are looking at
our client application for up to 115
units with access so the principle of
development with access will be for
debate I think it's prudent to show this
image to show how the site could be
developed and sent me taking account
with the landscaping the open space and
play areas the flood attenuation the
connectivity amongst the site and indeed
to the wide area the public right-of-way
which runs through the center and the
access points whilst this drawing may
seem a little chaotic conclusion to
include it because it does show how the
site would sit within the context of the
locality given the contour the line
Rises out of out of shot West but it is
predominantly flat as you can see from
the contour lines so in terms of the
landscaping this is an element that
officers have considered in depth and
you'll note that whilst this is
indicative we have sought to capture
this through condition there's no
objection from the landscape consultant
subject to a 10-year buffer advance
planting towards the frontage the site
is predominantly open and much of the
site as existing is arable field
your local flood authority also raised
no objection and again this is an
indicative permeability drawing but I've
chosen to include it as you know if the
site is approved there is every chance
that this come this could come forward
given the developable areas on the sites
of ography these areas the pink the
green and indeed during show your site's
sealed surfaces if you like however
these surface areas are permeable and
they are compliant in flood and water
tones so back to the master plan and we
now look at access access is a dual
access onto Fitzgerald Road as you can
see linking north from the access points
the visibility splays lonliness 30 mile
an hour stretch are adequately secured
in a 30 mile an hour zone the minimum
requirements along the x and y IE left
and right it's 43 meters in both
directions
the applicant is able to do is able to
demonstrate 70 meters in both directions
so this is why above and beyond what
your local highways authority would
require
it's now prudent to look at connectivity
and members will relate to the site
along the southern edge Fitzgerald Road
and the closeness of a built form but
also services facilities and amenities
and I've chosen to highlight the bus
stops as well I set out in yellow this
is a sustainable location your officers
have looked at the routine bus routes
and the site is well served sustainable
location adjacent and adjoining a key
service center among snips which fringe
with good transport options it's
imperative that sustainable development
provides the option for future owner
occupiers to use public transport and
indeed sustainable transport modes this
would be facilitated well given the bus
stops nearby and indeed the closeness of
High Street along with the shops that
are along this stretch so I'm now going
to take you through some site photos
members may wish to follow the map
bottom left corner or the site plan
master plan and the arrow the arrow is a
guide as to where the photo was taken
from and in what direction starting with
this first photo of the western fringe
you've got the pedestrian footpath and
on the west the dwelling is a Fitzgerald
Road along the north the site is as
shown a view east
as you can see the site is relatively
flat looking across the center towards
Brantford and the most suddenly
dwellings on Fitzgerald Road this is the
public right-of-way as you can see
well-worn that leads off into the top
right-hand corner of the site these are
the dwellings along Fitzgerald Road
taken from pretty much the center of the
site these are of two-story form this is
a view in the opposite direction you'll
see the public right-of-way on the
left-hand side of the photo and you can
see how far the land creeped up towards
the west outside of the site public
footpath Ochs at the site along
Fitzgerald Road and I've chosen to show
you this image from what I could find as
the highest point towards the west
looking down onto the siding you'll see
the site outlined in red I will just go
back you'll see the church tower
building here and basically the southern
extremity of Brantford the site isn't
greatly wooded or indeed subjects of
planting within the central belly of the
site the edges on hugely landscaped
either but there are several dense tree
and hedgerows along the western edge
uncertainly enhancement measures that
are set out through planning condition
are endorsed by offices so I'm going to
leave you with some facts and figures
and we can revert back to the traditions
I need and it is in the detail 9.0 light
hectare site for up to 115 units
35% secured for affordable housing which
are n DSS compliant naturally described
space standard so they are good quality
and that would be set out within the
section 106 the density is appropriate
as well and given the landscaping we
have looked to capture that we've got
highways compliant access and egress and
also flood water compliant management
there's also some contributions that
collectively along with other sites that
have Suffolk I that falls slightly into
the neighboring weber district that also
have an impact for this site and vice
versa in terms of highways contribution
those elements are captured so if this
site comes forward along with others
they would be highways contributions
that would go to mitigate through race
bus stops and highways improvements of
junctions public transport etc the early
years contribution and would be provided
off-site and that's a BC is indicated
build out your recommendation of from
offices is for approval subject to the
planning conditions in section 106 it is
a case of harms against the benefits and
inevitably there would be landscape harm
arising from newly built form and on an
agricultural field there is a negligible
heritage harm also which your offices
have balanced in the overall conclusion
but the benefits are abundant new homes
which are affordable open space
the early years building highways
improvements and landscaping and whilst
the district is able to demonstrate a
five-year land supply this isn't a
ceiling height the clear thrust from
government is to deliver homes and I'll
leave that for now
thank you but thank you thank you very
much thank you first of all in the
conversation box John field you have a
question John yes just an initial one
concerning the buses that you're talking
about we're talking about this being a
sustainable location and you mentioned
bus services I was just surprised the
numbers one one one one one one eye and
no an 88 is there anything special about
the noi night a NOAA night knowing that
these numbers indicate so the nature of
those buses secondly my belief is that
the bus service is four buses per day am
i incorrect in that that they travel
through sporting into hips which were
somewhat devious wrote so for a parish
with about four and a half thousand
inhabitants you have done we just need
let's just keep it - quick question
first question yes the bus the frequency
of the buses we've climbed it there
adequate there it's a good service what
is it and the bus numbers do two of
those indicating they're actually school
buses thanks jack so thank you for your
question and the reference is within the
report on the page 29 to the four bus
services I take from the County Council
website in terms of what is available
the frequency of those buses I can look
into and come back to you on I know that
the frequency is supported certainly
within the ex-witch fringe so allow me
to get back to you on the precise times
and
hours of those buses if I might say
you're on will be looking for whether
it's an adequate service considering
other services have recently been
withdrawn okay so what I'm gonna do is
I'm just going to run through it in
alphabetical order because like I
suspect we've got those who have got
questions I'm just going to get through
enough best law order so Jack are you
able are you looking that up now are you
happy to take other questions I'm happy
to take questions of course or we lay
the box on yeah and it might be someone
else can have a look at the bus
timetable while on your answering the
other questions okay so first up is
Rachel Rachel even Thank You chair I've
got quite a few questions well let's try
to keep it to three and then we can come
back to you okay
the in the papers it refers to some of
the consultation documents for 175
buildings where's the application is 115
so just to double-check that the parish
it's mentioned on page 16 that the Paris
plan is a material consideration and
I've not come across that before so
confirmation of that please and if I'm
only allowed three at the moment how do
what's the cycle route for pupils going
to Westbourne Academy and Claydon high
school so how will they travel from this
site to school by have got more
questions chair but okay so can you come
back from those three points to start
this yes thank you
the parish plan mentioned on page 16 so
is there there's a Paris plan area but
it doesn't come part of the development
plan so is a material consideration but
it's an appropriate way a limited way
the cycle routes that you are referring
to we'll get back to you on
and forgive me there was another
question wasn't there with regards to
something else some of the papers
supporting hate 175 so initially this
application came forward as 175 units
that's been reduced quite considerably
the comments that are contained within
have been assessed on units as well
given that this is a much lesser scheme
if content is still relevant
so procedurally I'm more than happy with
the comments that are set out how they
relate to the proposal that is before
you are you for 115 units okay so
another three Rachel thank you chair on
on the conditions it refers to
biodiversity enhancements and also to
sustainability measures can you detail
what these are please thank you that's
on the recommendations on page 44
thank you thank you in terms of and
biodiversity and ecology
there are skylark mitigation measures
required as per play services ecology as
a means of ensuring that there would be
no net loss or indeed there would be a
net gain in terms of ecology and
biodiversity the detail of those I will
just look for now so they are the
skylight and activation plots in
accordance with the habitat regulations
that we are bound to adhere to in terms
of sustainability measures this we've
been with mainly at reserve matters but
it would compel the applicants to
provide sustainability details at
reserve matters that would be above and
beyond what we would typically require
this is in essence a standardized
condition that we've looked to adopt
more recently given a the climate
emergency but also what the MPPs says so
what you would get are units that would
be discussed at detail and with a
pre-loaded sustainability emphasis on
them in terms of open market units and
of course of portables I'll come back
there on that through some thank you
very much jack it's just that you say
the sustainable measures sustainability
measures breed debt with a reserve
matters but because of a vision here I
just expect there to be more debt more
detail and will it therefore effectively
I think there's notes on supporting page
176 would it effectively cover what's in
that the consultation feedback from
information indeed I think so I will
just come back on that it's difficult to
pinpoint exactly what measures would be
introduced which is we're dealing with
application whereby we're only looking
at the principal and access once the
overall design and layout orientation
buildings is known and plots and indeed
numbers we can then look to introduce
the more acute details I think the most
important part is we're teeing the
applicant up to provide sustainability
and energy measures that are sufficient
and in line with with core policy thank
thank you thank you ok so just going
alphabetically next up is counselor fear
of John over to you for questions
thank you just a couple more points then
the passenger transport or requirement
you mention a sum of hundreds of seventy
thousand pounds I can't find any
indication of what that's for
so wonder if you could make that a bit
more clear I can see the blaze bus stops
and that sort of thing but they're quite
small
the second question really is about
highways mitigations the route from here
into X which is down the B 1067 which
you can see in the middle of the plan
before you and yet all these mitigations
appear to be in sportin perhaps more so
associated with other developments
except of course for the site or link on
Lorraine way which should take children
along to sup at one
so could you expand on those two things
a bit please thank you can't sir I think
it's whilst I'm on there's this drawing
or image I think that is an option to go
along the B 1067
off into what would be Branford Rose
heading up into Apes which outside of
the district and you've also got the
arterial route which is you'd be 11 1-3
South so you have got options whether it
be you know cycling or walking or indeed
by public baths that brings me on to the
public
one small element that you've mentioned
Suffolk County Council highways have
looked at the collective area in terms
of forgive me I'm going to go through
the drawings I've looked at the
collective area in terms of what could
be built out potentially and we do have
to plan for the future in terms of what
the site brings this is our application
site outlined as hatched in pink
outlined in orange the green adults are
approvals towards the north outside of
the district as delineated by the black
line in the parish of sprawl and in the
district of Weber the red dot is a
refusal and the orange dot is a pending
application disjunction amongst others
forms part of the consideration because
it is within the locality and is within
the jurisdiction of the county
councillors the where money is spent in
terms of the public highway
obviously the hundred seventy thousand
goes to the bus improvements that would
serve this development and it would go
into a pooled part there is nothing
before members to suggest that the site
would not benefit but given there is
potential this cycle go to appeal this
so I could be approved all of a sudden
you've got two more developments that
effect this site and vice versa that the
count accounts or duty-bound to consider
so we have to look at that I think the
most important part is that these
monetary contributions to upset these
concerns are included it would be a
bigger concern if they weren't the plant
the plants will do have that gift and
this is a consistent approach know how I
come in at this point chairman yeah Jack
do you have a wider aerial photograph of
anything wider than what you've got on
screen right now available I might have
yes
start because I think is just worth
pointing out that in respect of this
development and the burden that we are
obviously speaking to mitigate in
respect of this development you need to
look a bit wider in terms of where
travel will occur as a response to any
development on this site now Brantford
has its main linkage into its which but
it doesn't link on to the a14 the
junction plate link onto the a14 is just
outside of sportin the next Junction to
get to the a14 is in Clayton so of
course that makes the be Trevor one
three the main route if you like in
terms of cars coming off this site to
get to those relevant junctions if we
were to go further south beyond the
village of sportin you'd find that we'd
link up to what is known as walls II
Grange
pine wood and Tesco's and that is also
the cop dock interchange at that point
so this route is obviously part of
Suffolk County Council strategic
understanding of how the outside of its
which is going to work in the future and
obviously any development within this
corridor is is needing to contribute
towards that to mitigate his own burden
but also be part of a grander plan in
terms of understanding the transport
requirements of this side of Ipswich
just to mention while we're on this plan
are you able to point out Westbourne
High School because I believe that was a
asked earlier in respect of the route
and of course the route to get there
from Brantford would be along the be 106
7 which is a very standard Road it does
have a footpath along it all the way and
then of course you have to go into the
suburbia of Ipswich in order to reach
the Westbourne High School Clayton
Clayton High School which is in the
middle of Clayton that's a little bit
more difficult to get to you can go
along the path of road be trouble on
three but it is a 60 mile an hour Road
in places and doesn't have a foot
path in places you can get along what's
called paper mill Lane which is that one
there thank you that again doesn't have
any footpath among it for the majority
of it it is slower but there are blind
bends along that road so I would perhaps
suggest that cycling is not there are
public footpaths and you can walk to
plane and from Banford although it is a
distance but cycling is probably would
be more for older much older children
and adults if that was to be
participated into as an activity I would
suggest at the school bus that does run
through bonford daily well it did happen
so obviously lock down those
arrangements are obviously being
reviewed at the moment but being all vo
well that will be restored we'll run
through bonford and leads to Clayton for
any children as a veil abortion and I'll
leave it there thank you thank you
add John did you have any further
questions can I just come in i can only
see slide 22 so the whole of that
conversation does not relate to the
slide that i can see on my screen
am i seeing something different from
everybody else I can only see 22 so
something's gone wrong
what am I doing wrong we are not it we
have one slide in front of us you put
your head your screen frozen that's why
I'm asking I'm completely confused I'm
completely out of it because so what is
in front of you at the moment slide 22
which says bus stops okay so Jack can
you take the screen down and then we
you're off would get take it down and
then put it up again please screen back
up again now
okay so what do you thing that loading
I now see slide four but unfortunately I
was at a loss so I'm afraid I may have
missed the plot no problem so John can
you just go to the relevant page and
just just give us some Regan just I
think it's better that we're clear okay
what were the one John sorry John
Feynman G okay so I was saying that will
comes tend to talk and not think about
one talking about right let me start
again
so I was saying that if we look at the
overall picture of Barford in its
setting to its which and I did get us to
a plan that was indicating where the
Junction's were so ultimately any
development in Brantford is likely to
need access to the a14 Blachford itself
doesn't have access to the a14 so you
have to either go through the village of
sportin to get to the interchange which
is being indicated at the moment by Jack
or you need to go north and go to the
interchange at Claydon the alternative
option is to go all the way south
through the village of sportin and into
essentially it's- which we have pine
wood and Tesco's and the [ __ ] rock
interchange is also new development
there that is regarded as Wally Grange
within the weber district in terms of
the so we were talking about the
strategic contributions that would be
looking at that entire corridor between
Claydon and the wars ii Grange and kaak
kaak interchange because it's all
interconnected due to the triple 1-3
going into its which itself along the B
one O six seven that is the way you'd go
to get to Westbourne high school which
is just indicated there you then go into
the network of Suburbia a bit switch to
get to the school there is a good
footpath there is a good road
in order to go along there which is I'm
not aware of any issue particularly in
that respect to get to Clayton is more
problematic because you have to go
either along the triple 1/3 which is a
road that doesn't have a foot way all
the way around just about there with
after there's no footpath there and I do
know that from personal experience
because I used to bike along there in
order to get to needed market we do then
get to Clayton but the other root is
paper mill Lane again that doesn't have
any foot way so a cyclist would be on
the road for the majority of it and both
of those roads are perhaps not as
suitable as going into boots which where
they are slower traffic speeds and wider
straighter roads however there is a bus
service that goes through Brantford and
is a regular bus service for its and
that is available and put on by Suffolk
County Council thank you thank you
alright sir is there anything I need to
do to make sure it doesn't happen know
if it happens to shouting in the end
sorry
ok so John are you finished with your
questions next we go on to not entirely
finished I was just pointing out that
the questions and I was trying to ask
questions were what was the hundreds of
70,000 for parents in a transport for I
can see the small sums but what was the
bulk of it for I could come to what I'd
like it to be for but I don't know what
it's actually for the second question
really in a way John payment years as a
sort of Illustrated which is that the
highways mitigation I would expect to
help pupils and people you know people
who've done Drive perhaps people don't
wish to drive get in and out of Ipswich
as well as access the I 14 in both
directions and you'll have to sound
lived here for 30 years without knowing
where those junctions are and it just
looking at the highway mitigation
there's a cycle link on Lorraine way
which is from Brantford to sprawl
and that heads to sup at one good but
the vast the majority yeah other cash is
things like zebra crossing at the wild
man great for the pub I'm sure and
reduce curb radii in somewhere I know
not where and autumn okay but speak
around bat so the issue is what are
these things that will mm panting thank
you
essentially this goes into the pulled
part that is within the jurisdiction of
the County Council and I wholly
understand your concerns of where that
goes but I must stress that this is
largely dependent also on whether it is
needed given the other developments
within the locality that I outlined
earlier so highways mitigation such as
occurs except may be required this would
fall under the the roams of a section
two seven eight agreement the crucial
factor here is that we as a district
council are securing it and the County
Council would be delivering it through
tension to sever light that's all that I
can give you at this moment in time okay
thank you jack okay we now move on to
council having ham Lavinia do you have
any questions Thank You counselor
cerimon so you know Sarah Thank You
chair I also have a number of questions
so if I if I do three now and then I'll
think about the first one is we were
told at the beginning of the
presentation this is twin tracker
application and I just wondered if that
had any significance or any implications
presumably it means that they are both
identical and we have to determine both
of them I'm not I'm not quite good it
has any other implications that's my
first question second question is about
the early years provision because I
think the paperwork is a little bit
confusing on page 38 38 North pretty
lost a piece of paper one of our bits of
paper says that there
a early years building on the site but
on page 39 we have some information
about early years and infrastructure
provision and it says that it will be
subject to early years education
contribution intersection 17.1 in
section 18 point one it says additional
preschool places and existing
establishments so is or is there or is
there not a earliest building on this
site and my other question is about the
it's possibly to do with the fact that
there was a previous application but
some of our papers have an indicative
master plan which shows housing in the
far south of the plot and and and then
we have a slide which shows that as the
open space so can we be quite clear that
we're looking at the indicative layout
which has the open space at the bottom
of it yes Thank You councillor the twin
trucker is the form that the occupant
has chosen to submit through so we have
two applications are to be determined
today both are you are correct identical
and with the only difference being the
references the site is identical the
early years element is an element that
would be secured off-site there isn't a
provision on site the funding for the
provision built to BC is standard would
be secured through section 106 having
consulted the development contribution
as manager at the counter council in
terms of also apologies for the
confusion within the papers and that is
most definitely off-site based upon the
school places needed and the costs
associated the final question was to do
with the master plan this is the
indicative master plan
as you can see which is on slide 14
can't zoom out so can you see that
counselor Ansel can you see that Sara
yeah I've got slide 14 it's just that we
have some other slides in our paperwork
which had a different indicative master
plan I think yes page 231 this is the
proposed master plan and the elements
that are considered are set out as per
relying upon slide 14 for that purpose
trust that's clear check thank you can I
come back on another couple of queries
do we were told that the density was
twelve point seven or something like
that
now does that include that large area of
open space I'm assuming not presumably
that twelve point seven dwellings per
hectare is over the whole site including
that open space and I'm sorry I'm not
very good at road names in the Ipswich
fringe can somebody just point out to me
on a map where the rainway is thank you
for your questions I'll actually
included are you once live 32 counsel
announcer I am thank you very much
perfect so the third notch down is a
quantum mix of the types of attacks in
terraced houses you've got a gross and
net dwellings per hectare both of which
are compliant with policy so when you
include or not include the open space as
a whole or just a developable area both
are within compliance and you said a
question about the rainway which I'll
just get to
Lorraine why is that the Trevor ones
right indeed so it's this road here
extends all the way up so where is the
cycleway going all the way from this
site to where it goes all the way to
Suffolk one which is a college on the
edge of Pinewood in Ipswich in the
district of Weber so you have in essence
Lorraine way the B 11130 you can see
Lorraine Wayne marker there to the north
go to another image sorry that's better
so they're plating rocket Road and it
leads off from here all the way down
through past the side through sportin
and you may know the crossroads wildland
pub and off into the edge of it switch
so that links off the cycle rate thank
you sorry Matthew Mao just correct that
slightly yeah unless anybody knows
better the sixty thousand pound cycle
path goes from the top of Fitzgerald
Road the point more or less where that
red marker is and it goes down to the
wild man in sportin there's already a
footpath along there and it modifies
that we'll be good to go there and it's
possible to go the rest bar I don't
believe that actually is covered with
that sum of money fact thank you for
that John that so it's just a short
stretch along that be trouble 1/3 from
Branford to Sprott and that this
development is going to provide to an
existing existing cycle way from Sprott
to Suffolk one there's there's the
option to do that I can't give you that
answer because
in charge of the County Council function
ultimately the section 278 agreement
that County Council choose to implement
would provide detail on that okay okay
so any other questions at all think
that's it for now something else may
come to mind later no no yeah Casa
Matheson do you have any questions I do
thank you yes yeah I D I must say the
the presentation was excellent the one
thing that wasn't there that I was
looking for
subsequently surfaced a slide 41 and I
think it'd be healthy we could get that
one back again and I did really want to
understand the the relationship with the
other nearby developments of sorry well
applications etc that that John payment
he was speaking about but I wanted to
understand them particularly in the
context of the paragraph six point six
six point seven and six point eight
these these discuss the for travel
mitigation amounts of money conditions
etc and on this point yeah yeah
absolutely what what is what is worrying
me that I either is not clear is the
this this development that we're looking
at at the moment delivers some amounts
of money for towards contributions
towards these schemes the four schemes
that are listed at say paragraph six
point seven and the six point eight
discusses the the sequence in which they
might be delivered depending on the
other developments so I really like to
understand a bit more about that
because the the I would admit I was
expecting that the 6.6 seems to be
looking for the list of those
developments which John paint which is
now gone through hopefully all of the
relevant ones so if if they don't all go
forward and certainly at the moment
we're saying we've got one refusal and
one okay let's pick up this point about
that point okay Jack Thank You chair I
think the most important part is is to
plan well effectively if all sites were
delivers if so I could come through an
appeal this site is yet to be determined
which I trust you can see 0:41
yes thank you for putting it back up
again and running through it again you
call it council about so good and the
most important part is that if all
schemes are to be denied and that is a
possibility then there needs to be that
link-up of you know you can activity
made the most important part is that
these elements are captured yes we are
here to determine in pink would
contribute to the science at the north
and to the south and vice versa if
schemes are approved outside of the
district in Baber then pulled some of
money from both sides and upshot towards
the crop-top interchange where Tesco is
those things would contribute to this
scheme so you all have a collective
input it's a cumulative effect the most
important part is that it's included
rather than not included clear yet the
the my reading of paragraph 6.8 which
starts off saying the improvements
require all the developments to come
forward and society that we can see
that's quite possibly not going to
happen is that the
seems as if the cycle link is is the
last one that would come forward in
other words if any if any of the
applications that are currently been
refused etc don't happen then his cycle
link is the first thing that gets
dropped and I would be concerned at that
we're not you please no views at this
point it's just questions no I get that
but you do see I want to understand
exactly by saying it's a sequence with
the site at the end
sorry ciao I just want to hopefully be a
bit clearer
the bullets listed at Paris six point
seven are not sequential I'm not ordered
and by I just listed the important part
is that these four elements these four
bullet points I would be considered by
the local horizon our guarantee that the
fourth of it ie new cycle link between
Sprott and and Brantford would be lock
first there's no guarantee of that at
all we would be in the hands and the
jurisdiction of the County Council Thank
You chair any further questions drunk
yeah I think the the other thing which
counts on re burners as has touched upon
already is that you know can we be
assured that the the entirety of infarct
Wilson's proposed condition is will be
contained within the sustainability
measures condition the wording yeah of
course I think we've adopted a more of a
standardized sustainability measures
condition good which I trust you're
aware of and and this is you know common
with certainly major applications that
that we've adopted in in the past few
months so yes we can include that good
thank you that's all for now okay thank
you drunk next over to cats
rich Mayer really thank you
thank you just what kind of questions
um the page once we won this is there
are no surplus places in the local
primary school or secondary schools and
that very significant still funds would
be required to enhancer all those funds
going to be available and will the
schools be enhanced to expand it to cope
with the increased demands if this site
gets approved thank you for your
question Casa Maya
I think the duty of care and certainly
there is a duty within the County
Council function is that school places
must be provided whether that's at the
primary school with an asset nearby
secondary schools or whether there's a
bus provision if there's no space this
has been thrashed out that appeal on
quite a few occasions and it's a very
difficult topic to stand up if you like
the most important part is that the
County campus will have to provide
school places and certainly the SIL
funding and the silh injection would go
a long way to providing that so SIL is
included and the bit of where is it five
hundred and forty five thousand pounds
cerca that would go some way to divide
so those funds would be available and
then expanding that into the healthcare
is there any still provision to expand
the health services in the area which I
know are 671 below what they should be
already come in
ultimately the SIL the committee
infrastructure levy is a pot and that
pot will be you know distributed in
accordance with the council's
infrastructure plan and that obviously
plan gets worked up between the
the District Council and the County
Council in terms of the NHS as well you
know they are in can bid for money as
they see fit for expansion or
improvements to care within the area
that just as with schools and you know
we are working in these days in Reverse
you know the money will be put into the
pot and the money they seek in respect
of this development has been outlined
and that's I can't see any reason why
that wouldn't be provided on the
commencement of the building or the
phased commencement of the building and
then that'll be then up to other
authorities to seek the appropriate
money to go to the appropriate locations
in terms of school provision we don't
have any objection in terms of Education
to say that the relevant schools both
primary and high school within the area
and because we are close to its which
there is a fair choice don't have the
capacity to expand now as I do live in
this direction I do know that most of
these schools do have good capacity and
land available to them to expand if
necessary obviously being close to it
such as well there are various choices
in terms of doctors and and getting care
and clinics and so for also available
and it would be for the NHS Trust to
just receive monies accordingly through
any SIL bit they might make thank you
thank you questions not a question
specifically do occasional Hicks but I
can provide some clarification to the
question raised by John field earlier
regarding the public transport he is
correct there are already four buses at
the present but because the early bus
service leaving stow marking it switched
by Branford was withdrawn last year
thank you okay so anyone else got any
further questions yes please yeah yeah
who's this
Sarah yeah okay I do have another
question um
on our indicative layout which I believe
is slide 12 of our papers I can't
remember if it's the same one on the
presentation which is I admit it's only
an indicative housing mix but the
numbers at the bottom of that slide for
the open market dwellings do not tally
with the strategic housing needs which
were on page 142 of our report and I
wondered if anything had been said or
discussed about the open market housing
mix if I may come in on this particular
point in terms of affordable housing
remember members will find obviously in
our recommendation that the application
will be subject to a section 106
agreement and the affordable housing mix
is detailed there in full in terms of
both property sizes bedrooms and size of
property so we have that is completely
open and transparent in respect of this
application we have not and I'm
double-checking and Jack will correct me
if I'm wrong we have not sought to
secure the market housing mix in respect
of this application and I think that's
what I can say thank you so we're now
gonna move on thank you members and we
now move on where we ask the parish
council representative to speak and we
have Diane Australia who's going to
speak down you have three minutes and up
on the screen shortly we'll come a timer
without indicate for you the three
minutes just give it one second just
checking are you there
Donna yes I am okay so you can see in
front of you there's a three minute
timer which just gives you an indication
as you speak the time Olaf start so over
to you when you're ready thank you thank
you chair
I just wanted to start by saying
Bradford Parish Council has been
consistent in its concerns over these
proposals but has also tried to be fair
and objective in its responses and I
hope that comes across to the committee
it's also taking into consideration the
huge swell of public opinion in what
appears to be a significant objection to
this proposal and supports the parrot in
that just rich I just wish to briefly
reiterate what concerns the parish
council has heard previously raised ie
is it a sustainable development with
regard to the national planning policy
framework there is significant
development currently underway or
approved for approximately 300 dwellings
at the other end of the village it's
been mentioned already with suffix
five-year land supply is that relevant
and whether these proposals satisfy
certain strategic objectives are you
protecting the environment supporting
strong and healthy communities and
infrastructure we've spoken about the
buses being reduced the public
right-of-way through the center of the
development and is there any further
information from highways as to the
potential effects of the decision to
close Brantford Lane recently made
suffice to say the the parish councils
response did refer to a proposal for 13
houses on the site made back in 2002
it's believed that some of these reasons
for refusal are still relevant today the
development was described as a visual
intrusion to the detriment of the rural
character this is the only remaining
view of some of Brantford most historic
buildings the church which is grade 1
listed it was described as a car centric
development with issues regarding the
access on to and from Fitzgerald roads
due to the sharp end one end and parking
along the road probably now exacerbated
by significantly increased
of cars on the road over 20 years and
then there's the desire by static
counsel it's not the County Council at
the time to retain the character and
future use of public rights-of-way
a sentiment still echoed today with the
County Council's desire to improve the
access to green spaces it's hoped the
committee will take into account these
issues when considering these proposals
thank you very much thank you very much
for that okay members do we have any
questions for the parish council I have
one yes councillor Mansell again I would
just like to ask the parish council
representative if there has been any
communication consultation whatever the
word is between the developer and the
Parish Council on this application no
there hasn't thank you thank you could I
ask from the parish basically the
sustainable transport into Ipswich is
the current situation satisfactory to
the residents of the village no it
hasn't been for a while a meeting last
year when the 89 bus was withdrawn
generated 50 residents attending the
meeting and there's still been no
resolution as to what's going to replace
it at this time okay any other questions
nope okay thank you so we're now going
to move on thank you very much next we
move on to an objector Caroline Walton
Caroline again do you have three minutes
to address the committee and again and
you'll have the time I'll just be reset
for you there we go okay and over to you
are you there yes thank you chairman
thank you you'll see from your reports
our residents feel strongly about this
development and on our greenfield site
there lies outside the village boundary
597 objections have been sent
to you across the to applications by our
community expressing their concerns the
village of Brantford have had the
planning approval of 512 Wellings since
2015 which is a 48% increase in housing
with two large developments to the north
of the village of 325 dwellings which
are still under construction this
development is for a further 115 homes
to the south Sheila 2019 states
branchless to provide 295 dwellings the
local planning authority is to is able
to demonstrate that it as an adequate
five-year housing land supply is not
identified in the Paris plan and is
located outside of the defined
settlement boundary therefore this
development is beyond policy requirement
and not currently needed the site must
also be considered in context of a
multitude of sites along the dipping
valley corridor contributing to massive
cumulative growth and an almost
continuous ribbon of development along
the beach over 1/3 these sites show a
clear demonstration of creeping
coalescence of ribbon development which
the MPPs specifically warns against
place Services landscape report states
the views will be adversely impacted
upon as a result of the development the
special landscape area and views of the
Gipping Valley Riverwalk would be
greatly affected along with the footpath
that cuts across this site with views of
the grant policy cs5 states that will
protect and conserve landscape qualities
this development does not it will be an
inevitable change to the character of
the existing agricultural land causing
landscape home the wider heritage views
will be effective and affected and
Suffolk Preservation Society states and
Mary's Church and Street Farm Cottage
listed buildings are still at risk and
recommend a further reduction of
dwellings in line with Shilla and Japan
JLP the site had planning application
for 13 dwellings refused in 2002 as
mentioned by the clock and it was
refused due to the detriment of the
rural character and appearance of the
area it again shows that this
development of 115 dwellings it's not
appropriate on this site as 13 were
refused this field performed
many functions for wildlife recreation
flood risk and food production is of
huge value to the community and should
not be used for housing development when
other sites are available Brantford has
the brownfield site of thousands on
paper Mill Lane this site is sustainable
and ready for development and PPF States
development of available brown seals
field sites must be completed as a
priority before Greenfield is considered
many thanks thank you very much do we
have any questions at all from members
yeah I have yeah okay yeah you you
mentioned in the middle of your comments
the the MPP if I wonder what paragraph
that was and whether officers can help
us with with that little more so which
which point is being made in the MPP F
thank you I'm terribly sorry I don't
have the paragraph available obviously I
could look that up okay John or Jack can
you help us with that which question
that the question of coalescent saw the
question of brownfield versus greenfield
I think it was it was the coalescence
point actually give me a moment or I'm
behind if there were maybe just look at
myself
like I've just had a look John and I'm
not sure whether you found anything but
coalescence isn't really discussed
within the MP pen so there's no word to
that effect I know that there's case law
that's come out from South Norfolk with
regards to settlement coalescence and it
comes down to it's a straight shootout
on landscape grounds and whether the
coalescence would be too close to the
body of another settlement or indeed
another village
I think the coalescence aspect is an
important part that we certainly have
considered because it's a poignant
matter
I think the separation distance between
Brantford and sprawl and is adequate
more than adequate given the stretch
along the Rhine why John have you got
anything to add upon that I am still
looking and I will continue to look I
can't find anything either
obviously I'm looking also at the
section within the NPP F about Greenbelt
but of course that applies to think
Greenbelt and obviously people often
take that out of context I do recall in
terms of mid Suffolk one of the debates
about coalescence was where we have
stone market and Stowe upland but that
literally was half of the half a field
between the village boundary and Stowe
market Cedars part development in this
case I either there is a greater
distance but Barry I think we need to
move on and if I can find something I
can certainly bring that to a members
attention okay next up we have an
opportunity for a supporter to speak but
we have no supporters come forward and
just checking there's no supporter who's
come in
no okay next we now ask the applicant
Chris Smith to speak again you have
three minutes to address the committee
and we'll just be resetting the timer
Chris morning chairman yes okay over to
you and your three minutes please
Thank You chairman members my name's
Chris Smith island development planner
for Hopkins Homes has been outlined by
your offices the site lies in a wholly
sustainable location on the edge of the
settlement of Brantford within walking
distance of a good range of local
services and facilities and forms a
draft local plan allocation with the
unit within the emerging joint local
plan through positive working with your
offices since the application
submissions in the spring of last year
the requirements of all statutory
consort ease are now able to be fully
addressed thus enabling your office's to
be confident that their proposals will
provide a high quality sustainable new
development within an attractive
landscape setting forming a positive
visual enhancement to this southern
entrance to the village as you've heard
the proposals will deliver up to 115 new
dwellings which up to 40 will be
affordable homes in full accordance with
existing policy in association that we
over four hectares of new public open
space alongside all the requested
financial contributions towards other
essential infrastructure or the sale and
section 106 procedures in summary
therefore we trust that you can can
compare with your office's
recommendation and that you're able to
support the proposals Thank You chairman
and as always I'm happy to answer any
questions that members may have thank
you okay we're going to open up to
members I guess the first one is from me
and around engagement with the parish
council we like to comment on that yes
we had a public consultation event at
which the Parish Council were present
coming up for two years ago now when the
concept of the development was put
forward and obviously members of a
parish council and indeed local
residents had the opportunity to to have
their say we had a very good turnout to
that event and obviously there are a
variety of opinions offered and some
some more positive than others and on
that basis you know we then took the
application forward to where we are now
new policy not to engage with parish
councils no no certainly we're happy to
engage with why didn't it on this one
explain I think it was it was clear that
the parish council weren't in favor of
development principle and on that basis
it's difficult then to have a positive
dialogue but say we've we've not just
gone to the parish council we've we've
held an event locally where there's why
you just you know not get involved with
the parish council because we always
find that this committee that if parish
councils engaged with the applicant you
get a much better decision-making
process but obviously so you made a
decision you did not want to engage with
the parish council because they weren't
supportive that's the answer you've
given we've always been open to dialogue
with the parish council but we've
obviously David made their position
clear so they doesn't there's not been
the opportunity really to to engage
further in that respect but door was
always open and we're happy to talk to
to anyone yeah okay and then I'm sure
the exactly the same their doors always
open because they meet monthly okay so
you chose not to gauge the pressure
council thank you
any other questions yes I'll have one
yeah just about the indicative plans I
always find these slightly uncomfortable
huh and one understands the principle
perhaps but we have a range of
indicative plans here which we're told
to one on screens the right one we have
in the past often ask developers whether
they were prepared to see a condition
that says essentially the developments
should be broadly in line with or in
centrally in line with the indicative
plan just to make sure that we haven't
boast our opinions on a load of
make-believe yeah and in terms of yes
certainly the indicative planets on the
screen before you now has evolved over
time through the process to the
application and consultation with your
offices and as your office has said with
your councils landscape consultants our
intention would be to bring forward a
reserved matters detailed application
that broadly Accords
with that that layer and obviously in
putting this layout in the public domain
people will rightly expect that any
reserved matters clip fairly closely
aligns with with what's shown on the
plan here so you'd agree with a
condition yes I don't see a problem with
a condition worded that you know any any
reserved matters submission should
broadly align with the detail shown on
this indicative layout because you know
the end of the day we're not here to
join um try and join come forward with
something different you know we're
trying to establish at this point in
time a layout that we feel would that we
could build to and accept me no missteps
and indeed a high-quality appearance and
inform and scale and and fit with the
carrots for the locality and in the area
and indeed in accord with the the main
things on here and you'll note one here
the lines that are showing in terms of
views to the church views through to the
special landscape area in the river
alignment of the public footpaths and
and yes we'd like to to be able to come
forward with the layout that that you
know does accord with that sort not a
problem with the condition to that
effect nine I've just got one on the
question I just asked
obviously under the recommendation
that's enough papers on page forty four
forty five it talks about obviously the
affordable housing access five percent
can you confirm that you won't be coming
back with a further application to
change that that that will actually stay
as is in the future yes chairman I don't
see any reason why we should need to do
that um you know we've had discussions
with the offices it's an outline up to
115 dwellings we feel that 115 dwellings
can be accommodated on here and
therefore that's why we've had this
indicative layout to to try and share
her that could be achieved and within
that layer the the requested amount and
layer of affordable housing should be
deliverable so now I don't see that
there should be any needs it even if
there's an economic down because I just
think about to frowning and when you
there was an economic downturn and you
went back and train check out the
affordable so your view is that the
affordable here and the shared ownership
will stay in place even if there is
economic downturn yes chairman I mean it
just for other members reference the
framlingham saw it was a brownfield site
that had last additional costs over and
above what would normally be anticipated
this is as you've heard a Greenfield
previously undeveloped site so there
should be no reason for us to come back
on that point great thank you for that
okay any other questions no okay thank
you very much for that thank you okay we
now move on to the board member can Sir
James Caston James over to you thank you
very much mr. chairman as you will see
this application has a huge amount of
public objections and comments this is
actually nine times more objections than
the the Willowbrook and semuc sites
which were a hundred and 85 and 115
dwellings it's more than those put
together for this one this one site of
115 houses and it's goes to show that
the the residents of Brantford are open
minded to development but this
particular one is completely
unacceptable to them whenever I've
spoken to residents in Brantford the
Fitzgerald development has been a major
issue throughout the village this
application was considered seriously
damaging by most residents this is also
my position on it I feel that
development is completely unacceptable
for the position which I'll talk about a
bit further the whilst against whilst
against Fitzgerald Road there is a site
development at the Feist ins on paper
mill lane the Feist ins area this is one
of the last arable fields visible and
usable and
to the residents so I'm going to talk
now a bit about the quality of land in
the planning application there was a
land grade assessment the field is
downgraded to a grade 2 because of its
intolerance to drought this is because
it's free draining in the expected crop
and land use survey it is designated as
76 suitable for cereals sugar beet and
other arable crops some fruit and
horticultural crops thus all tends to
dry out but in the in the pictures which
I think are quite useful you can see how
green those some fields are it lays in
the perfect position for irrigation of
high-value crops which would bring it as
good as any grade one land which of
course we know mid Suffolk does not have
any grade one land in the in its whole
area what better position for use of
water that is drained away from men
Mendelson in the future in a future that
will be shaped for the need for water
and this attenuation what attenuated
water can be used for something useful
the in the winter time that sugar beet
was some lifted off this field and it
was cultivated within days I don't think
any young farmers would disagree that
this was a terrible year and probably
the hardest in a generation for lifting
sugar beets and and at working land it
was so incredibly wet it is now a really
respectable spring barley field which is
in itself incredible considering we
didn't have any rain during the whole of
April and May in branford this is this
is field is delivering food into the
market in a year where most fields have
really struggled the only real issue for
this
the field is I can imagine is the
grazing of the Wildfell going into the
river because it's some it backs onto
the floodplain as you know the the only
the area of the stirrin or well Esther
is some special protection is adjacent
to the site and it's an incredibly
special world life corridor
taking more farmland away from this will
not deliver the biodiversity net game
you taking the type of land there is an
asset Wildfell and wildlife associated
with the river and replacing it with
gardens and that harbours a very
different type of biodiversity a
biodiversity that is not needed by a
river if you add domestic cats and dogs
barking into the mix which I'm ok and
dog owner myself I haven't got a problem
with it but you will find that these
creatures have a much harder time
surviving this is the second to last
arable field that lies between the beach
rubble 1/3 or Lorain way and the B 1067
which is the paper mill Lane and
Brantford Road either side of the
village it's the only arable field you
can now see as you drive home from
Ipswich from your drivers side it's it's
the only arable field with a footpath
that leads to sprawl turn and then
Ipswich it is iam it's a route taken by
the local gyms and running clubs they
can still use it but they'll be running
in an urbanized environment the people
of Brantford Drive out of Ipswich and
come home to the incredible view of the
special landscape area with the grade 1
listed mates st. Mary's Church and the
amazing backdrop of historic woodland
and they reminded that they live in a
row
not a suburb and you can see from the
photos there I don't know which side it
was but there's some really good photos
of that incredible view
Branford has resisted being swallowed up
into it's which over the years and it's
which has tried to include it but it
remains mid Suffolk a resident told me
recently they are very proudly mid
Suffolk it's a rural village it must be
must not be incorporated into a town
it's not the identity of the village
building further towards the boundary of
sportin is destroying that that village
identity building building further
towards that boundary as well is the
definition of coalescence this will
leave only a small field between the
development and the border of Baber
which is an issue because we will no
longer have any control over stopping
these village has been linked together
and potentially risking in boundary
changes losing the economic value of
Brantford to another district so the
land is productive and it's a definite
loss with and a lots of opportunities
for the future I don't believe there's a
there's a net gain for biodiversity it
damages the village identity the the
loss of that field is urbanization
natural england say that this
application is likely to have
significant effect and i totally agree
with them the visual amenity in the view
from beach the beach over 1/3 or
lorraine way and the footpath will be
gone forever and it sits outside the
settlement boundary housing supplies
another issue I'd like to raise we've
recently had large developments approved
that go along the beach at one 395 how's
the semuc site which is not built yet
which adds to 754 approve dwelling
you